[Musik]
sie leben fast wie vor 300 Jahren die
Amisch in den USA eine religiöse
Glaubensgemeinschaft die ihren Ursprung
in Europa hat
ihre Regeln heißen Ordnung dazu gehört
die Erwachsenen Taufe und je nach
Strenge der Gemeinde die Ablehnung des
technischen Fortschritts sie tragen
altmodische Kleidung Güte und Tauben
lange Bärte wer den Amis begegnet taucht
in eine vergangene Welt ein
[Musik]
Name ist Ines mein Name ist iNOS labo
ich bin verheiratet mit Martha Müller
jetzt labo wir haben sieben Kinder wir
sind Amisch der alten Ordnung und leben
auf einer 38 Hektar großen Farm
[Musik]
wir versuchen die Technologie so weit
wie möglich zu vermeiden alles was wir
von uns fernhalten ist besser uns
gefällt das zu viel Technologie bringt
nur Probleme
der 40-Jährige Ines ist Farmer und
Hufschmied seine Kinder sind zwischen 55
Jahren alt die slemex Leben in
mittelfield eine der weltweit größten
amischgemeinden in Jogger County Ohio im
Nordosten der USA
die Arme der alten Ordnung sind
pferdeorientiert wir benutzen keine
Autos und Traktoren
ja das ist eine lange Tradition Pferde
zu benutzen das ist unsere Lebensweise
die Art wie wir die Pferde dafür
zusammenbinden wie wir drei
nebeneinander arbeiten lassen hat mir
schon mein Vater beigebracht als ich ein
kleiner Junge war so haben wir es
gemacht
es ist halb sechs Uhr morgens die beiden
ältesten Söhne der 12-jährige Markus und
sein Neunjähriger Bruder Myron helfen
den Vater bereits vor Schulbeginn im
Stall
wir füttern die Pferde
und spannen Sie ein
und nimm das Saatgut mit
Leben nach der alten Ordnung ohne Autos
kein Fernsehen oder Computer
stromerzeugend nur mit Hilfe von
Batterien und Generatoren
Ines besitzt 21 Pferde der für die
Farmarbeit und Kutschenfahrten vermietet
außerdem lebt er vom Verkauf der Ernte
und von seiner Arbeit als Hufschmied
[Musik]
was immer ich an Futtermitteln selbst
erzeugen kann muss ich nicht kaufen
mit dem eigenen Anbau spare ich etwa
3000 $ im Monat das sind 36.000 Dollar
im Jahr die man so verdient
ich meine wenn man das spart ist es ja
gutes Geld dass man nicht ausgeben muss
das lohnt sich
immer dabei die Söhne mag es und Maren
ja sie haben morgens zu tun stehen früh
auch wird dann alle Tiere und machen
sich dann fertig um in die Schule zu
gehen dann kommen sie nach Hause und
fangen wieder von vorne an
die Schule beginnt um 8.30 Uhr und ist
drei Kilometer entfernt
[Musik]
wenn der Respekt und das Verhalten von
klein an gelehrt werden begleitet sie
das durch den Rest ihres Lebens was man
ihnen in jungen Jahren beibringt
begleitet sie ihr ganzes Leben lang
[Musik]
dazu tragen auch die 350 privaten Arme
Schulen in Ohio bei die Amis Zahlen
kommunale schulsteuern dafür dürfen sie
ihre Privatschulen mit eigenen
Lehrkräften betreiben ob zu Hause in den
Gotteshäusern oder in der Schule in
Mittel fehlt wird immer gemeinsam
gesungen allerdings nur religiöse Lieder
[Musik]
es gibt nur eine einzige Klasse darin
werden die Kinder zwischen 45 Jahren
unterrichtet die Bibel nimmt den meisten
Platz im Unterricht ein erklärt Lehrerin
Kathleen
am Morgen singen wir meist Bibelverse
beten dann das Vaterunser dann schreiben
wir normalerweise etwas dann
Rechtschreibung rechnen und Vokabeln
lernen
nach dem Mittagessen haben wir
normalerweise Englisch und Erdkunde und
das war es auch schon und Deutsch haben
wir normalerweise auch als erstes am
Morgen
nach der achten Klasse mit 14 Jahren ist
Schluss mit der Schulbildung und wenn
jemand weiter lernen möchte
das weiß ich nicht das habe ich noch nie
gehört dass jemand zu mir kam und wollte
Arzt oder Pilot werden er Fabrikarbeiter
Schreiner Maurer so gut wie alles
die Bibel hat für Kathleen Priorität
das ist sehr wichtig das erwarten wir
hauptsächlich von der Schule die Bibel
und Gott nahe bringen
[Musik]
möchte braucht kein langes Studium man
wird erst einmal Hilfskraft und läuft im
Unterricht vier Jahre lang mit
darüber hinaus werden private Kurse
angeboten und Lehrer Treffen organisiert
um Erfahrungen auszutauschen
wie überall an der Schule ist die Pause
das schönste auch nach
Unterrichtsschluss übernehmen die Kinder
Aufgaben zu Hause so der zwölfjährige
Raymond
wir gehen gleich nach Hause unsere Väter
und Mütter wollen dass wir dann
mitarbeiten manchmal spielen wir auch
normalerweise haben wir keine
Hausaufgaben auf
in dieser Schreinerei werden Küchen und
Schlafzimmermöbel hergestellt
beschäftigt 13 armisch-mitarbeiter da
Amis kein Computer besitzen dürfen
erhalten Sie Ihre Aufträge über einen
Dienstleister der sie auf Papier vorbei
bringt mit Hilfe der Generatoren und
Batterien laufen die vielen Maschinen im
Betrieb erlaubt das die Gemeinschaft die
Auftragsbücher sind voll
ob wir uns nicht ein bisschen mehr
modernisieren als unsere Eltern ich
denke schon jede Generation macht das
aber wir versuchen das beizubehalten was
uns wichtig ist die Pferdekutschen das
ist unsere Art der Fortbewegung aber in
unserer Arbeit und unserem Geschäft
haben wir auch Fahrer die unsere
Produkte ausliefern sie bringen uns zum
Ausmessen zu den Kunden und so weiter
[Musik]
gehört der alten Ordnung an doch jede
einzelne amischgemeinschaft im Land
entscheidet selbst darüber wie weit man
sich der modernen Welt anpassen will
eins steht aber immer fest
Kirche und Familie haben immer Vorrang
vor dem Geschäft zumindest sollte das so
sein
das sollten wir uns immer vor Augen
halten
[Musik]
geschäftlich muss Rey erreichbar sein
daher ist ein Telefon mit
Anrufbeantworter in der
amish-gemeinschaft der alten Ordnung für
die Geschäfte erlaubt nur nicht im Haus
zu viel Technik stört das Familienleben
wenn mich jemand anruft beim Abendessen
lasse ich es einfach klingeln und esse
weiter nach dem Abendessen und beten im
Haus nehme ich hier Gespräche an
Ray und Mary haben neun Kinder zwischen
6 und 20 Jahren alt die
älteste Tochter lebt mit Mann und Kind
auch auf der Farm
[Musik]
ich kümmere mich um die Kinder
um die Kleidung der Kinder halte das
Haus sauber
die Ehemänner gehen normalerweise raus
haben einen Job bringen das Geld heim
und unterstützen damit die Familie
die Rollenverteilung wird bedingungslos
akzeptiert so steht es in der Bibel das
Oberhaupt ist Gott dann kommt der Mann
dann die Frau dann die Kinder
untereinander wird pennsilouania Dutch
geredet einem kein süddeutscher Dialekt
vermischt mit englischen Wörtern
wir sagen krumbären-schellen ich schäle
normalerweise meine eigenen Kartoffeln
aber ich hatte in meinem Garten dieses
Jahr nicht so viele also habe ich diese
dazu gekauft
[Musik]
normalerweise habe ich erst Zeit für
mich wenn die Kinder im Bett sind oder
eine Stunde morgens wenn meine älteren
der neuen Kinder schon arbeiten bevor
die Jüngeren dann zur Schule gehen
also habe ich von sechs bis sieben Uhr
Zeit das ist normalerweise meine Zeit
[Musik]
Mary holt vor dem Mittagessen noch
schnell die Wäsche rein
14 Personen leben hier
ich habe sechs Waschmaschinenladungen
jedes Mal wenn ich wasche
Handtücher und die dunkle Wäsche hängen
da drüben davon habe ich gewöhnlich fünf
Wäsche Ladungen
montags mittwochs und freitags
das gemeinsame Gebet vor jeder Mahlzeit
ist Tradition bei den Amish
Kartoffelpüree und Fleisch kommen fast
immer auf den Tisch
[Musik]
mit den eigenen Händen das Anbauen was
die Gemeinschaft braucht das sind bis
heute die Tugenden der Amis geblieben
doch nur noch sieben Prozent dieser
Gemeinschaft leben ausschließlich von
den Erträgen ihrer Felder
Ines muss die Pferde wechseln
[Musik]
die anderen Pferde sind jetzt müde
von der Arbeit in der Sonne und Hitze
sie müssen Wasser trinken
der Taxi kommen seine Frau Mary und
Tochter Rachel vom Einkaufen zurück für
Pferd und Kutsche sind die Geschäfte zu
weit entfernt
ich bin hier um Ines und seine Familie
irgendwohin zu bringen wenn sie irgendwo
hin wollen oder müssen das weiter ist
als ein Pferd und eine Kutsche sie
hinbringen könnte
[Musik]
ich möchte kein Amis sein ich bin zu
sehr an die Lebensweise gewöhnt die ich
habe aber ich verstehe warum sie das tun
was sie tun es ist Teil ihres Lebens und
das ist in Ordnung ich habe kein Problem
damit genau
die gerade 15-jährige Tochter Rachel hat
vor einem Jahr die Schule beendet und
hilft auf dem Hof mit sie kümmert sich
hauptsächlich um die Wäsche und sieht
nach den Pferden
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich werde ich auch mal
heiraten und Mutter werden
dann möchte ich auch weiter mit den
Pferden arbeiten
[Musik]
ich mag mein Leben so wie es ist und
würde es mir auch nicht anders wünschen
ja ich mag mein Leben immer noch so
Chester kurz ein Freund von Ines komm
mit seinem Pferd Granny auf die Fahrt
[Musik]
mein Hufschmied ist und der muss das
Pferd dringend neu beschlagen und die
Hufe müssen bearbeitet werden
chester ist kein Farmer er ist Bauleiter
und Subunternehmer vermittelt Handwerker
und wohnt sieben Meilen entfernt
[Musik]
das Pferd spürt nichts du kannst das
Sehen ist zockt nicht einmal
Nachwuchsprobleme kennen die Amis nicht
denn bei fast 8000 Pferden in
mittelfield und Umgebung ist Hufschmied
ein garantiert krisensichere
Arbeitsplatz
es gibt fast keine jungen Amerikaner
mehr die sich dafür interessieren nicht
so bei den Amisch
man weiß dass es Arbeit ist und da steht
bei der neuen Generation nicht so auf
der Tagesordnung nicht so viele Leute
machen so einen Job
in den letzten fünf Jahren haben so
einige Amisch angefangen es gibt ein
paar junge armische Hufschmiede die
wirklich gut sind
[Musik]
schließlich ist Granny fertig 400 Dollar
kostet ein kompletter hufsatz
Chester macht sich gleich auf den Weg
denn seine Kutsche braucht auch noch
neue Räder
fast 370.000 armisch Leben in den USA
die meisten in Indiana Pennsylvania und
Ohio allein dort gibt es mehrere tausend
Kutschen auch Buggys genannt
viel Arbeit für einen kutschenbauer wie
er Joda als Großvater gehörte diese
Werkstatt Chesters
wolltest du das heute Nachmittag machen
ja ich habe den einen Reifen schon
fertig ich muss sie nur noch in die
Schmiede legen und aufheizen
[Musik]
früher waren nur Holzräder mit Stahl
darauf erlaubt jetzt fahren die meisten
Arme Schräder mit Gummi
die Regeln der Ordnung haben sich in den
letzten zehn Jahren geändert
das ist nicht nur bei den Kutschen so
aber unsere Kultur ist in der Lage sich
anzupassen wenn wir strenge starre
Regeln hätten und unseren
Lebensunterhalt immer noch so verdienen
würden wie im 18 Jahrhundert könnten wir
nicht überleben
wir könnten nicht konkurrieren ich denke
der Grund warum wir als Kultur noch
überleben liegt darin dass wir uns der
Wirtschaft und dem sozialen Druck
anpassen können
es ist uns gelungen die Menge an
Technologie die wir als Ordnung zulassen
so zu regulieren dass wir trotzdem ein
Gleichgewicht zwischen unseren
familiären Werten und unserem Geschäft
halten
die vier Räder für Chester sind fertig
und Kosten 1.600
[Musik]
2 Kilometer von Elli oder entfernt lebt
Chester mit Familie auf einer kleinen
Farm sieben Kinder haben er und seine
Frau Martha
sie leben zu Hause auch nach der alten
Ordnung der Amis wenig Technologie Strom
von Generatoren und Batterien
altmodische Waschmaschinen und geheizt
wird mit Holz aus den eigenen Wäldern
[Musik]
während der covet-krise und all den
Turbulenzen die es weltweit gab konnten
wir eine Lebensweise beibehalten die den
inneren Frieden fördert
der ich glaube nicht dass das möglich
ist wenn man rund um die Uhr mit den
sozialen Medien und der Außenwelt
verbunden ist
Unternehmen arbeiten mit Programmen und
sofortiger Kommunikation
das ist großartig für ein Unternehmen
ich bin aber so froh dass ich mich zu
Hause davon zurückziehen kann und das
ist der Weg um einen Verstand zu
bewahren
[Musik]
im frühen Morgen geht es in seinem
Baugeschäft per privataxi denn die 20
Meilen zu weit für Pferd mit Buggy
[Musik]
heuchlerisch findet er die Lebensweise
der Amisch aber nicht nur weil sie in
ihren Geschäften und Büros die moderne
Technik verwenden dürfen
[Musik]
für die Arbeit ist es erlaubt wenn ich
es selbst nicht besitze zu Hause nein
[Musik]
um erfolgreich zu sein Geld zu verdienen
und unsere Familien zu unterstützen
könnten wir nicht konkurrieren wenn wir
versuchen würden mit Handsägen hämmern
und Nägeln Häuser zu bauen dann hätten
wir keine Arbeit denn das würde viel zu
lange dauern und niemand könnte diese
Aufträge hier annehmen
Chester war früher Zimmermann und Maurer
laut der Studie des Elisabeth town
College in Pennsylvania sind über 80%
der armischen Unternehmen sehr
erfolgreich
ich war nicht auf dem College ich habe
nicht einmal einen Highschool-Abschluss
meine Kenntnisse habe ich durch die
praktische Arbeit ich lernte von meinen
meistern und Lehrern ich denke das liegt
einfach an unserer Arbeitsmoral wir
neigen dazu klein anzufangen und unsere
Dienste gleich anzubieten wir Arbeit mit
unseren Händen dafür gibt es immer eine
Nachfrage es ist also sehr wohl möglich
mit lediglich acht Jahren
Schulausbildung einer erfolgreicher
armisch-geschäftsmann zu werden
in der Umgebung von middlefield betreut
Chester mehrere Projekte wie dem Bau
dieser zwei Millionen Dollar Villa eines
amerikanischen Geschäftsmannes
[Musik]
auch Schulabgänger Wayne hat hier gerade
angefangen der 14-Jährige Sohn seiner
Cousine
[Musik]
ich muss Merkel anmischen und dafür
sorgen dass immer genügend vorhanden ist
manchmal muss ich auch überschüssiges
Material entfernen
aber ich mag das
[Musik]
15 Dollar die Stunde
so beginnt das und wenn er mehr
Erfahrung hat wie der Top-Manager in
unserer Firma dann bekommt er 32 Dollar
die Stunde
[Musik]
nur ein geringen Anteil ihres Lohns
dürfen die amisch-kinder bis zum 20
Lebensjahr behalten bis dahin bekommen
die Eltern den Lohn
einige Leben auch weiterhin zu Hause
dann zahlen Sie etwas Miete für ihr
Zimmer und die Verpflegung
[Musik]
jeden Sonntag feiern die Amischen
Gemeinden ein dreistündigen Gottesdienst
in einfachen Gemeindehäusern außerhalb
der Stadt tom ist hier seit 34 Jahren
Pfarrer
[Musik]
believe wir glauben an eine ewige
Bindung wenn wir heiraten wir glauben
nicht an Scheidung du kannst kein
Mitglied unserer Kirche sein und dich
scheiden lassen wir betrachten die Ehe
von Mann und Frau so wie es in der Bibel
festgelegt wurde wir bitten Sie ein
Leben lang zusammen zu bleiben und es
ist ziemlich selten dass es bei uns eine
Scheidung gibt es kann passieren aber es
ist ziemlich selten
Schnitt haben Familien sechs Kinder ein
Geschenk Gottes
wir haben Leute die medizinische
Probleme haben und deswegen keine
weiteren Kinder mehr bekommen
medizinische Ursachen sind ein Grund das
ist okay aber wir glauben nicht an
Abtreibung keine Abtreibung
[Musik]
sie singen Lieder aus dem ältesten
Gesangbuch der Täuferbewegung was bis
heute ohne Unterbrechung in deutscher
Sprache genutzt wird der Ausbund
wer als getauftes Mitglied die
Gemeinschaft verlässt wird
exkommuniziert Kontakt ist weiterhin
erlaubt mit der Familie aber an einem
Tisch zu sitzen verboten
90 Meilen entfernt leben Leute und
etnamilla mit ihren sechs Kindern sie
betreiben ein Hof mit Solarenergie haben
Strom aus der Steckdose ein lokales
Handy fahren E-Bike und Quad sie leben
von ihren 50 Milchkühen und den Erträgen
ihrer 40 Hektar großen Farm
Ätna hat alle modernen Küchengeräte ihre
amischgemeinschaft Alter Ordnung erlaubt
es
würde sagen die meisten arme Leute haben
eine Art Mixer manche Leute die keinen
Strom haben haben solche Mixer aber sie
werden mit einer Batterie betrieben sie
haben eine Batterie die an der Rückseite
befestigt ist aber bei uns ist es so wir
haben Strom also nutzen wir die
Elektrizität
Ätna sieht vieles pragmatisch über Tabu
Themen wie Verhütung und Sexualität
redet sie offen
[Musik]
in my case ich glaube besonders in
meinem Fall
wir hatten zwei Kinder die wurden mit
Kaiserschnitt geboren
die anderen vier sind auf natürlichem
Wege geboren
aber der Arzt sagte uns dass es ein
Risiko sei noch mehr Kinder zu kriegen
wir haben einfach beschlossen dass es
reicht und haben Verhütungsmaßnahmen
ergriffen
ich denke also wenn die Gesundheit der
Frau auf dem Spiel steht ist es nicht
falsch das zu tun wenn die Gesundheit
der Frau in Gefahr ist aber es nur aus
egoistischen Gründen zu tun etwa weil
man nicht mit weiteren Kindern belästigt
werden will halte ich nicht für richtig
ich möchte nicht das Bild zeichnen dass
die Armes perfekte kleine fromme
Menschen sind das sind sie nicht immer
denn es gibt Fälle von Inzest unter den
ammischen das ist sehr traurig wenn es
Menschen gibt die keine persönliche
Beziehung zu Gott haben dann passiert so
etwas
aber es gibt solche Fälle und sogar
Väter die ihre Kinder sexuell
missbrauchen das ist bei den armischen
auch passiert
und es ist so traurig es ist sehr
traurig und es ist eine Schande
[Musik]
viele Vorteile in der armischen
Lebensweise sieht Ednas man läuft
kam gerieten die Menschen in Panik
so dass sie heute nicht einmal mehr
wissen woher ihre Lebensmittel kommen
und das sind reale Probleme
und ich denke dass wir nicht völlig
abhängig sind
wir kaufen etwas Treibstoff aber im
Großen und Ganzen könnten wir uns eine
lange Zeit selbst versorgen
vor allem innerhalb der Gruppe von Armes
Leuten die wir persönlich kennen könnten
wir eine ziemlich lange Zeit ohne
jegliche Hilfe von außen überleben
für ihr Land und den Präsidenten in den
Krieg zu ziehen lehnen die pazifistisch
eingestellt und Amisch ab dennoch
respektieren Sie die politische Führung
als von Gott bestimmt
ich habe noch nie gewählt ich habe noch
nie für jemanden gestimmt
und das ist unter den armen Leuten sehr
umstritten wir folgen dem was Jesus uns
gelehrt hat als er sagte dass derjenige
der das Schwert nimmt und sich
verteidigt durch das Schwert auch
getötet werden wird
und er sagte auch wir sollten die andere
Wange hinhalten
wenn wir also wählen wenn ich wähle und
den Oberbefehlshaber wähle der Präsident
ist der Oberbefehlshaber er ist der Chef
der Armee wenn ihr hingeht und befiehlt
dann würde ich das Vertreten Rapper
sending ich habe großen Respekt vor der
Autorität ich respektiere unseren
Präsidenten nicht respektiere unsere
Führer gott hat diese Leute bestimmt und
ich respektiere das
gebetet wird auch hier traditionell beim
gemeinsamen Mittagessen
zwei ihrer sechs Kinder leben noch auf
der Farm Tochter Julie und Sohn Jason
Ätna fährt immer per E-Bike auf
Einkaufstour das ist für sie schneller
und bequemer als ein Pferd vor dem Buggy
zu spannen
die hügelige Landschaft wäre auch für
die 12 Meilen hin und zurück zum
nächsten Supermarkt zu anstrengend für
das Pferd
eingekauft wird meistens nur das was man
selbst nicht im eigenen Garten oder auf
seinen Feldern hat
[Musik]
ich brauche ein paar Lebensmittel in
großen Mengen so was wie Mehl und Zucker
um mein eigenes Brot zu backen
dieses Obst und Gemüse hier sieht so
attraktiv und schön aus aber ich brauche
es nicht zu kaufen weil ich es in meinem
eigenen Garten anbaue
ich glaube es ist einfach ein gutes
Gefühl sein eigenes Gemüse anzubauen und
ich weiß nicht ob alles gespritzt ist
und so bei mir zu Hause ist alles
biologisch und ich weiß wo es herkommt
also ist das ein gutes Gefühl
nur einmal in der Woche fährt Etna zum
Supermarkt
der Tag beginnt für die Millers früh um
4:30 Uhr
täglich werden die 50 Milchkühe gemolken
die Biomilch und das Fleisch ihrer Kühe
sind sehr gefragt
wirtschaftlich geht es ihm nicht
schlecht der Milchpreis steht hoch die
Millers können von den Erträgen gut
leben
auf der Farm arbeitet weiter die jüngste
Tochter Julie mit
ich weiß was meine Aufgaben sind also
kann ich es selbst planen an einem Tag
arbeite ich besonders hart und dann am
nächsten Tag habe ich frei nach der
Schule haben die Amis die Möglichkeit
einer Auszeit die rumspringer-jahre
beginnen
ich habe nicht wirklich rumspringer
gemacht aber ich war schon in Florida
ich würde das nicht wirklich rumspringen
nennen ich habe dort nichts gemacht was
ich nicht auch zu Hause mache also
nichts verbotenes oder unangenehme
Sachen
nicht weit von Julie hat sich eine
Gruppe rumspringer verabredet
Jugendliche zwischen 16 und 20 Jahren
jetzt dürfen sie Dinge tun die sonst
verboten wären rauchen Alkohol trinken
oder Autofahren am Ende dieser Zeit
müssen sie sich zwischen der modernen
Lebensweise und der der arme schon
entscheiden also du stehst zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht wirklich unter der
strengen Ordnung
ich meine deine Eltern werden dich
ermahnen aber als Jugendlicher neigst Du
natürlich dazu manchmal ein wenig vom
Weg abzukommen
[Musik]
rumspringe ist die Zeit das ist der
Zeitpunkt an dem man an den Wochenenden
seine Eltern verlässt und mit seinen
Freunden ausgeht
in dieser Gruppe wird regelmäßig
geraucht und Alkohol getrunken
meistens ist es nur eine Gelegenheit an
den Wochenenden zusammen abzuhängen und
sich zu verabreden
und sich eine Partnerin zu suchen
[Musik]
man kann sein ganzes Leben lang
rumspringer sein aber im Grunde hört es
für dich auf wenn du Mitglied der Kirche
bist nachdem man getauft wurde
bei dieser Gruppe haben sich die
Ansichten schon so gefestigt dass sie
nicht mehr auf alles Neue anspringen was
ihn die Welt so zu bieten hat
[Musik]
jeden Tag brauchen wir Gott an unserer
Seite um uns zu führen und um uns
durchzubringen wir sind dabei auf
unseren Glauben angewiesen und ich denke
wenn wir versuchen seinen Lehren und
allem zu folgen wird er uns durch
schwere Zeiten bringen ganz sicher
[Musik]
wir sind also immer bestrebt unsere
Zukunft zu verbessern und je mehr wir
unseren Kindern Respekt beibringen sie
disziplinieren damit sie gehorchen desto
besser wird die Zukunft der Amisch sein
ihr wirtschaftlich unabhängigeres Leben
ist moderner geworden ihren Grundsätzen
und Werten aber sind sie treu es bleibt
jedoch ein vorbestimmtes und
abgeschiedenes Leben von der Außenwelt
[Musik]